we need to we need to get a grip we need
to be stronger we need to be better we
need to stop covering ourselves in
Cotton wool and thinking it's okay to be
weak it's not okay to be weak the real
world is Harsh the real world is going
to throw things at you you've got to
learn to roll with the punches otherwise
you won't survive uh I'm afraid it may
not seem like it in today's day and age
with everything that's so easy but it
really is survival of the fittest and
you've got to be the fittest and today
unfortunately that is being emotionally
fit you you've got to be able to to take
things and you know you've you've got to
strive for better you've got to strive
for gold